Or like a peach you before in our relationships and in our you.
Wow.
Can I be like,
oh Flolan Logan right to we're not there yet.
No,
thank you for coming.
Did you bring multiple resumes?
I have like two or three extremely unprofessional.
Oops.
You got the job.
I can hear you.
Yeah.
That's like one hair that's like,
if it's like one hair that's like sticking up.
That's one hair sticking up so you can hear me.
We were dressed up in costumes.
Okay.
I was Starfox,
she was a Miss Marvel Nyan Cat Mashup cosplay and,
and we were at a convention,
so there's like thousands of people around us and like you can see her in like,
it's like a needle in a haystack.
Could not take my eyes off for the first time I saw her at the headphone.
Yeah.
So we met on Halloween and I was deep in my phone planning all the parties we
had like three different parties were going to,
and I was with a huge group of people and John Wasn't even a part of our group.
He just randomly stumbled up and was like,
who was tough guys?
And I look up and it was like God shined a light.
I'm getting flustered just talking about this.
He had his sleeves rolled up and his arm,
I'm saying this
is arms look to,
so I got,
I was like,
who is this man?
I said that uh,
you're very attractive.
Very attractive.
Okay.
We went to a barcade and uh,
we went and played her favorite pin ball machine.
I'm from the east coast and there's like nothing like that over there.
It was like the coolest date I've ever been on in my life.
I'm not going to lie.
I was really,
really nervous to go on this date with him because I was,
I felt like I was starting to like him and I didn't want him to know.
I also wanted to feel still like I was in control of this situation just in case
he was a jerk or too good to be true.
But we ended up having like a really good time.
We just like talked for like hours,
just about all of our favorite things and kind of got into a little bit more
like serious talk about like our past relationships and what we expect.
And it was just nice.
He was so easy to talk to in.
I hated it because I started to really like him.
I came out here and I just wanted to like work.
We were going to be good friends and we're gonna help each other.
I'm going to do stuff like that.
And um,
I tried to do that with you
when,
cause we had been kind of like dating for so long and you're like never tried to
kiss me.
I Dunno.
I didn't want to like mess things up.
You didn't want it to happen.
I think I was just scared of it happening and I'm like,
I've been in other like longterm relationships in the past and I felt like I
just put up with the person into sound reasons that like things that we had in
common but never really felt like I connected with them.
And with John it felt so instant and scary in right away.
And kind of like what they talk about in the movies.
Yeah.
Like it makes me nervous,
right?
Yeah.
Our biggest fight so far,
we're planning on moving.
She really wants to move inward towards Los Angeles and I want to move like out.
I want to move like have like trees and grass and stuff like that.
Cause that's like how am I grew up?
I guess we're trying to come up with the best points to art.
Do you know
I have depression so when I'm like really hard on myself or things go really
bad,
I can spiral pretty quickly.
And um,
we got in this huge fight and it boiled down to the way we treat each other.
Um,
in the balance,
the imbalance in a relationship,
how is just work all the time.
There's,
there's no time for us and no time for me.
How can we be happy together?
And initially I was just like,
fine,
just like forget it.
I'm done.
Like we don't need to be together.
It's easier for me to be alone.
That's what I do when I'm like hurt and I want us to have something quickly,
I push away.
Uh,
luckily John's very patient,
um,
can see through that mid pack.
Like,
all right,
well if something's wrong here,
I just,
something bothers you.
You just,
you got to tell me.
We have to be honest.
And uh,
if I was working too much,
you know,
he'd tell me,
he'd be like,
all right,
enough.
Now it's time to take a break.
It was like we're loving each other in a different way.
Did,
did,
did you say the fight,
the fight?
Uh,
Jardine,
Dang it.
I brought up the big fight that we had in June.
They asked how I,
we've gotten over it and I think as just being honest and setting harsher
boundaries has really,
really helped.
Even though it was scary,
I'll be honest,
I knew we were going to figure it out.
See,
that's a positive mentality all the time.
When I first met met Megan,
I didn't even,
I didn't know she was,
I honestly,
I didn't really watch you tube.
I even know what the terms of youtube are.
Men.
I guess I was just nervous because I never been in the spotlight before.
I've seen the magazine covers in grocery stores where like all of this drama
happens in Hollywood between actors and stuff like that.
Do we,
do we try to stay private?
Did we not?
Did we go public?
I guess I changed the way that I presented myself to the public on social media.
That was just more kid friendly.
I think the biggest struggle that uh,
John I go through is separating our day.
The life of a Youtuber is 24 seven and I've been doing it for so long and it's,
it's not a very stable career choice.
You're fighting for relevancy.
My workdays can sometimes be,
you know,
16 hours or I wasn't sleeping at certain times.
I would get maybe two hours of sleep and a,
that would really affect our relationship because John would be like,
there's no balance.
We work all the time,
but there is no time to relax.
If you're relaxed,
you feel guilty and it hasn't been easy and because we have something so
special,
it's definitely worth fighting for more.
We're picking it out.
It's bigger.
Yeah,
I dunno if you guys have a word for it.
I do.
Me and my,
my brother do.
We were like,
if we could ever find that the true one is the golden leopard.
It's the golden leopard right there.
You know the unattainable person that matches your personality so perfectly.
And you know,
literally few days after Megan and I were seeing this as becoming a
relationship,
I was like the Golden Leopard is,
is not even the right word.
Like she's a Rainbow Unicorn.
Know like riding on a rocket ship
psych you,
you searched your whole life for this feeling that you read about in fairy tales
and you've seen in movies,
but you kind of like come to terms with the fact that doesn't exist.
I met John in it.
I know it's just right.
Even though I'm over here in La and yeah,
all my family is back on the other coast.
I feel like home with you,
you know,
and I've always felt like an outsider here.
You're my best friend and I love you.
Wait.
Hey guys,
thanks for watching.
If you liked that comment down below,
what's your favorite part was?
Click up here to subscribe and right here to watch more videos catch you later.
All right,
cut.
What?
Cut.
What.